was there a point in time where you kind
of just stepped away from music yeah i
quit music in 2013 at the end of 2013.
and was that like a hard thing for you
to do man because i know you know i know
this industry will spit you up chew you
up and spit you out man it was too much
that was going on
you know
i left rca
it just wasn't it's a shitty label
unless you're a priority shout out to
rca but god bless them but yeah if
you're not a priority [ __ ] they had d1
on rca forever and they know what the
[ __ ] to do anyway i digress i left and
then i lost a lot of money in 2013 not
working
and i had 414 in my bank account and i
was like man i'm not doing rap no more
and then 2014 comes around and i'm like
i couldn't get a job
because i hadn't have i hadn't worked
since 2007.
so by april
when i realized that i couldn't get a
job i was like well it's on the rap
again and that just kind of was my
resurgence and i went into my plan b
which was just being this emcee that can
just that just goes to just raps and
people just kind of you know it just
continued to snowball snowball snowball
snowball snowball
and now you know i am i'm i'm here you
know yeah i think what's dope is like
now
uh there is no middleman if you want to
drop music you just get a distrokid
account
and you're on and you're on and you can
run up your indie catalog and even if
you have
a thousand fans that are your core fan
base there's a way to monetize that and
and make a living off of this rap [ __ ]
yep you just tell everybody like you got
to be consistent and you have to like
figure out how to get to a point where
you have enough fans that are like die
hard fans it could be 500 kids
and if they support everything you do
and you're strategic and you're smart
you're going to be able to pay your
bills off rap music
you know what i'm saying
you turn 500 into 600 and and so on and
so forth and i think that's what's kind
of been dope about like uh
somebody like you know
what griselda has done is like they've
just racked up so much catalog
and russ who took a page out of your
book shout out to russ russ you know did
a one song a week for a year
but it's like just
betting on yourself
knowing guess what not every record is
going to be a hit no it doesn't work
like that but it's okay
because every record someone's going to
listen to it and it just communicates it
all adds up like it all builds up it all
adds up and i think that's what matters
right like being able to
you know put out content that your
supporters really appreciate
and they want to support you because
they feel like you're giving them the
soundtrack to not only your life but
their life and that matters to them a
lot so you know and also put you in a
dope creative position because now
you're just giving people what they want
not what the people on the 52nd floor
wants right because they're all about
numbers and analytics like now you guys
i'm mickey facts people [ __ ] with me
because i can wrap my [ __ ] ass off
right so let me give y'all some of that
that's why that's how i got here that's
how i got here and that's how we gonna
stay here yeah straight up man well look
uh the album is out go support it the
narrative me blue knots make sure you
guys go pick that up it's crazy